Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und hier sind wir jetzt angekommen in der 48. Ausgabe, in der es wieder einmal um eine Planetenmission gehen soll. Nachdem wir jetzt schon fast alle Planeten des Sonnensystems abgeklappert haben, steht natürlich noch einer aus, den eigentlich so viele Nachrichten umspült, insbesondere in den letzten Wochen und Monaten, nämlich der Mars. Und darum soll es gehen, aber nicht um den Planeten, sondern zunächst einmal um die Mission der ESA zum Mars, Mars Express. Und um darüber zu reden, begrüße ich Johannes, Johannes Bauer. Hallo, guten Tag.
Ja hallo, hallo Tim.
Wir sind hier wieder im ESOC. Ihr werdet es euch schon gedacht haben, in Darmstadt, dort, wo diese Mission eben geplant und durchgeführt und geleitet und überwacht werden. Und ja, du bist Teil des Mars Express Teams.
Genau.
Was ist da deine offizielle Aufgabebezeichnung?
Okay, meine offizielle Bezeichnung ist Spacecraft Operations Engineer. Und meine Aufgabe im Team umfasst unter anderem, das Lage-Regelungssystem zu betreuen und zu überwachen und mich um eventuelle Probleme damit zu kümmern. Und zum anderen für die Missionsplanung, das heißt also die tagtäglichen wissenschaftlichen Pläne vorzubereiten und den anderen Operations Engineers dann zu überreichen, dass es dann zum Raumfahrzeug geschickt werden kann.
Du bist jetzt noch nicht so lange dabei bei dem Mars Express Team?
Nein, ich bin erst seit letztes Jahr, also im Jahr 2011, im Juli dabei. Habe davor aber auch schon als Trainee in demselben Team und habe mich da schon mit Lage-Regelungen befasst vorher.
Und wie ist überhaupt dein Weg so in die Raumfahrtwelt gelaufen? Also Mondlandungen hast du wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr so richtig aktiv mitbekommen?
Ich habe vorher Physik studiert und habe das im Jahr 2006 abgeschlossen. Und habe aber während meines Physikstudiums die Gelegenheit gehabt, bei so einem ESA Student Parabolic Flight mitzumachen. Parabelflug, genau. Und das war also sehr interessant. Das hat mich auf die ESA gebracht. Das hat mich mit der Raumfahrt in Verbindung gebracht. Vorher war ich, ich würde das schon sagen, auch Raumfahrt begeistert. Das hat mir auch alles imponiert und gefallen. Aber ich hätte nie gedacht, da selber was damit zu tun zu haben zunächst mal. Und dann seit dem Parabelflug, da war ich hin und weg. Das hat mich sofort fasziniert. Das hat mich ergriffen.
Kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Ich hatte ja auch schon mal die Gelegenheit. Da ist man nicht mehr genauso, wie man hochgekommen ist.
Da ist mir dann zum ersten Mal die Idee gekommen, ich könnte das zu meinem Beruf machen und versuchen, in die ESA reinzukommen. Ich habe mich dann informiert, wie man in die Raumfahrtwelt einsteigen könnte. Da gab es unter anderem die Möglichkeit, ein Studium zu machen. Das nennt sich Space Master. Es gibt einen zweijährigen Aufbau-Master-Studiengang von der Europäischen Union aus, so einen Erasmus-Mundus-Studiengang, der ist in Würzburg. Es ist aber nicht nur in Würzburg, sondern es geht über vier Semester und man kann sich, also man ist da theoretisch bis an bis zu drei verschiedenen Universitäten und zwar, also in Würzburg müssen alle anfangen, ein Semester, das zweite Semester findet dann in Kiruna statt, im Norden von Schweden und im dritten Semester. Also Kollegen von mir, die haben dann auch an dem BAEXUS mitgearbeitet später für ihre Masterarbeit.
Also die Ballon-Experimente hatten wir hier in der Ausgabe 45 mal genauer schon analysiert.
Und nach dem Kiruna-Semester kann man sich dann aussuchen, an welche von sechs Partner-Universitäten in Europa man dann weitergeht für das zweite Studienjahr. Und dabei bin ich nach Toulouse gegangen. Die anderen Möglichkeiten wären gewesen wieder zurück nach Würzburg oder in Kiruna bleiben oder nach Helsinki, Prag oder Cranfield in England zu gehen.
Und ein bisschen Toulouse.
Da bin ich nach Toulouse und hab dann meine Masterarbeit bei ASTEC in den Niederlanden durchgeführt.
Das ist ja schon ganz gut rumgekommen.
Ja, und danach habe ich mich eben für Jobs in der Raumfahrtbranche umgeguckt und bin dann nach einem kleinen Umweg als German Trainee vom DLR aus hier nach ESOG gekommen und habe beim Mars Express Flugkontrollteam ein Jahr absolviert als Trainee. Wollten Sie das eben nicht mehr geben lassen? Genau, da gab es eine freie Stelle und das hat sich gut getroffen.
Na super. Ja, kommen wir auf die Mission selbst. Der Mars bewegt die Gemüter, das merkt man immer wieder. Und in diesen Zeiten, wo gerade auch das Mars Science Laboratory, besser bekannt als Rover Curiosity, gelandet ist, merkt man wieder mal so eine emotionale Wahrnehmung, auch der Raumfahrt, die jetzt nicht unbedingt täglich stattfindet, aber die dann sich immer wieder festmacht an so bestimmten Sachen. Das macht immer so den Eindruck, dass Mars Missionen da einen besonderen Stellenwert haben.
Ja, weil Mars Missionen, denke ich, haben deswegen einen besonderen Stellenwert, weil der Mars ein himmlisches Objekt ist, auf dem man wirklich auch landen kann und auf dem es so etwas zu sehen gibt, wo Atmosphäre ist. Zumindest eine Restatmosphäre ist. Ja, Restatmosphäre, das was noch übrig ist. Aber so von den ganzen Planeten und Monden, die es bei uns im Sonnensystem so gibt, ist das auch einer mit der interessantesten und der erdähnlichsten, sage ich jetzt mal.
Und auch noch relativ leicht zu erreichen.
Ja, erreichbar in Griffweite sozusagen.
Trotzdem hat sich die ESA lange rausgehalten. Die ersten Missionen zum Mars sind, glaube ich, von den Amerikanern durchgeführt worden oder waren die Russen? Da sind ja viele auch gescheitert, also der Mars ist ja auch ein Missions-Friedhof in gewisser Hinsicht. Viele haben es gar nicht erst geschafft.
Ich glaube, Russland hat so um die 15 Missionen zum Mars geschickt. Teilweise auch nur Flybys dabei, aber trotzdem 15 Missionen, die gescheitert sind und fünf Missionen, die dann entweder ein Flyby oder sogar eine Landung oder ein Orbit dann auch wirklich geschafft haben. Aber fünf aus 20, das ist schon eine ziemlich hohe Fehlerrate. Und bei den Amerikanern ist auch nicht immer alles glatt gegangen. Von daher kann Europa auch wirklich auf Mars Express sehr stolz sein, weil es war von Europa aus der erste Versuch, zum Mars zu fliegen und das hat dann auch gleich geklappt.
Wenn auch nicht ohne Probleme, wenn wir gleich auch nochmal genauer analysieren wollen. Trotzdem, also es war also schon was Besonderes, die Mars Express-Mission für die ESA. Warum heißt das Ding dann Express? Weil es schnell gehen sollte.
Genau, weil es sehr schnell gehen sollte. Normalerweise brauchen solche Projekte mehr als zehn Jahre Vorbereitung von der ersten Idee, von den ersten Designstudien bis zum Launch dann letztendlich. Aber bei Mars Express war das nur im Zeitraum von etwa fünf Jahren. Und zwar hat es damals ja auch eine russische Mission gegeben, die heißt Mars 95 und die ist fehlgeschlagen, schon beim Start. Und es gab dann einige wissenschaftliche Teams, auch unter anderem europäische wissenschaftliche Teams, die ein Instrument an Bord hatten von diesem Mars 95. Und da kam dann die Idee auf, dass man eben einen europäischen Satellit basierend auf dem Rosetta Bus, so nennt man das sozusagen die Karosserie von einem Satelliten.
Rosetta ist wiederum die andere ESA-Mission, die wir hier auch bei Raumzeitausgabe 20 schon mal besprochen haben. Da geht es halt der lange Weg zu den Kometen, um dort dann auch ein Länder fallen lassen zu können. Das liegt jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch vor uns. Aber das war dann sozusagen die Plattform, die man sich gegriffen hat. Genau, die Plattform, so heißt es ja. Und inwiefern war die so geeignet? War das die einzige, die da war? Oder hat sich das aus anderen Gründen angeholt?
Na ja, das war eine Plattform, die schon konzipiert war für Deep Space Mission. Von daher brauchte man nicht mehr viel zu ändern, um jetzt weit weg von der Erde zu fliegen.
Kostenersparnis und Zeitersparnis ist natürlich etwas, was in dem Feld eine große Rolle spielt.
Genau, weil viele Komponenten hatte man schon geprüft und entwickelt und die waren alle schon für Rosetta vorbereitet. Und so ist es eben jetzt auch bei Mars Express. Die ganzen Subkomponenten im Raumfahrzeug sind mehr oder weniger identisch zu den Komponenten in Rosetta. Und auch Venus Express, wobei Venus Express mehr oder weniger eine fast identische Kopie von Mars Express ist.
Genau, das hatten wir hier vor zwei Ausgaben schon. Da klang das schon an, dass man es da ja so richtig leicht gehabt hat. Nicht nur, weil man zum zweiten Mal von derselben Plattform zähren konnte, sondern es auch von dem Instrumentarium sehr ähnlich zu Mars Express war und vor allem Mars Express schon mal alle Fehler machen durfte, die man dann bei Venus Express dann erstmal so nicht aktiv bekämpfen musste. Da bin ich jetzt sehr gespannt auf den Weg. Das heißt, wann ging es los? Der Start war 2003, 2.
Juni 2003, von Baikonur Cosmodrome ausgelauncht und dabei ging noch alles glatt. Allerdings musste man schon ziemlich gleich nach der Anfaltung der Solarzellen, der Solarpanele feststellen, dass wohl nicht der komplette Strom zur Verfügung stand, den man eigentlich erwartet hat.
Warum?
Weil anscheinend bei der Herstellung des Satelliten ein Kabel vergessen wurde. Ein Kabel.
Ein einzelnes Kabel. Was nicht konzipiert wurde oder was nicht dran war.
Das wurde einfach beim Zusammenbau sozusagen nicht vergessen einzubauen und der Test, der das überprüfen sollte, ob alles richtig verkabelt ist, der wurde abgesagt aus Kostengründen. Und dann hat man das eben erst gemerkt, wo es schon zu spät war. Und dadurch hatte die Mission von Anfang an schon 30 Prozent von der Leistung, von der Stromleistung, die zu erwarten gewesen wäre, weniger gehabt. Und so eine Raumfahrtmission wird natürlich immer mit Überschuss konzipiert, aber der Überschuss war dann eben schon weg.
Okay, das heißt, man musste dann auf den eigentlich geplanten 100 Prozent fahren sozusagen.
Genau. Und das Team hat dann auch im Laufe der Zeit gewisse Methoden entwickelt, um Strom zu sparen und eben da ein bisschen vorsichtiger mit der verfügbaren Energie umzugehen.
Das rächt sich dann immer, wenn man nicht genug testet.
Genau. Ja, aber der Satellit pflegt ja immer noch und ist sehr erfolgreich. Von daher muss man eben kleine Hürden überspringen, aber...
Der Flug war dann wahrscheinlich auch wiederum sehr direkt?
Der Flug war direkt, ja. Das war so ein sogenannter Hohmann-Transfer, so eine Halb-Elypse von der Erde zum Mars. Und das ist so von der Transfer-Energie her das kostengünstigste für den Treibstoff. Man fliegt am Perizentrum von einer Elypse um die Sonne, wenn man sich eine elliptische Flugbahn um die Sonne vorstellt, wo man am Perizentrum bei der Erde ist, auf der Erdumlaufbahnhöhe und am Apozentrum auf der Marsumlaufbahnhöhe, dann fliegt man eben am Perizentrum an der Erde weg und kommt dann genau am Apozentrum am Mars an. Dazu muss man eben genau in einer bestimmten Konstellation zwischen Erde und Mars losfliegen, dass der Mars dann auch da ist, wenn man ankommt.
Perizentrum, Apozentrum, muss ich jetzt noch mal fragen, was sind die Flachen und die beiden Endpunkte der Ellipse? Man lässt sich sozusagen um die Sonne herumfallen und am Ende ist man dann da, wo der Mars dann sein wird.
Genau, man muss sich erst einmal aus dem Erdgravitationsfeld befreien und dann noch einen kleinen Schubs nehmen, um jetzt auf eine Umlaufbahn zu kommen, die elliptisch ist und weg von der Erdumlaufbahn geht. Und dann, wenn man beim Mars ankommt, muss man auch noch mal einen kleinen Schubs geben, um eben oben auf der Mars-Umlaufbahn zu bleiben. Allerdings, das wird dann von der Mars-Gravitation schon mit erledigt. Da muss man sogar noch abbremsen, damit man nicht am Mars herbeifliegt.
Das heißt, man muss den Flug dahin gar nicht groß powern, sondern man hat sich einmal von der Erde gelöst. Dann treibt man einfach in die richtigen Richtungen korrigiert, die Flugbahn gegebenenfalls noch ein bisschen. Wenn man dann da ist, geht es eigentlich nur noch darum, so langsam zu sein, dass dann die Mars-Gravitation einfach so einfängt.
Genau. Es gibt ein Abflugmanöver von der Erde, das relativ viel Treibstoff verbraucht. Dann gibt es unterwegs Korrekturmanöver. Und dann am Mars gibt es wieder das Ankunftsmanöver, das einen dann in die Mars-Umlaufbahn einschießt. Da muss man abbremsen und sich von der Mars-Gravitation einfangen lassen. Aber dann hat man den Hauptteil des Treibstoffs verbraucht und der Rest ist dann übrig, um geringfügige Orbit-Manöver am Mars zu machen.
Was war denn jetzt das eigentliche Missionsziel? Was wollte man erreichen? Wofür ist Mars Express konzipiert worden? Ich meine, wenn es die erste Mission ist, ist alles offen. Es gab noch nicht so viele erfolgreiche Missionen bis dahin. Was war sozusagen das eigentliche Kernziel?
Das eigentliche wissenschaftliche Kernziel ist, wie bisher immer noch bei den anderen Mars-Missionen der NASA, eben den Ursprung des Lebens im Sonnensystem zu erforschen. Da ist eben der Mars ein Punkt, wo man am Ersten vermuten könnte, dass es Leben im Sonnensystem bereits schon vorher gegeben haben könnte oder vielleicht eventuell sogar immer noch dort existiert, in Form von Mikroben möglicherweise. Jetzt nicht so, dass da irgendwelche Marsmännchen rumlaufen, aber wenigstens mikrobiologisches Leben. Das ist auch das Kernziel der Mars Express-Mission, möglichst Spuren von Leben zu finden. Das heißt wiederum auch Wasser zu finden, weil Wasser ist ein essenzieller Bestandteil des Lebens. Von daher zielen eben die Instrumente darauf ab, Spuren von Wasser zu finden und die Zusammensetzung der Atmosphäre zu untersuchen, die Zusammensetzung des Bodens zu untersuchen, auch unterirdisch nach etwaigen Wasservorkommen zu suchen und auch um die Oberfläche zu kartografieren.
Und also sozusagen so eine Universalbeobachtung, um einfach möglichst viele Details auch mal in guter Qualität zu haben. So eine komplette Oberfläche, die Struktur, die übliche Analyse von Zusammensetzung der Restatmosphäre, der Oberfläche. Welche Instrumente hat man denn dann Mars Express mitgegeben, um das zu erreichen?
Ja, da ist unter anderem zum Beispiel MARSIS. Das ist ein Radargerät, mit dem man unter die Mars-Oberfläche drunter schauen kann, in Tiefe von mehreren Kilometern.
Wie macht man das?
Man sendet niederfrequente Radarimpulse, also bis zu 5 MHz-Bereich, zwischen 1 und 5 MHz-Bereich. Die werden dann von verschiedenen Schichten in der Mars-Oberfläche, in dem Mars-Gestein zurückreflektiert. Das Echo wird dann an Bord von einer 40 Meter langen Radarantenne aufgezeichnet. Dann kann man aus der Intensität und dem Zeitablauf der Echo-Signale zurückschließen, wie tief die Schichten waren, an denen das Echo dann reflektiert worden ist.
Das heißt, wenn man so ein Radar möglichst niederfrequent betreibt, dann dringt man tiefer in die Erde ein?
Genau.
Normalerweise denkt man immer so, da haben wir jetzt so das, was oben ist. Aber wenn man bewusst niederfrequent macht, dann wie tief kann man da vordringen?
Also unser MARSIS-Radar dringt so viel ich weiß bis zu ungefähr 5 Kilometer.
5 Kilometer?
Also ich weiß, dass man Wassereis vorkommen hat, die bis zu 3 oder 4 Kilometer in die Tiefe gegangen sind. Ich weiß, dass es eine NASA-Mission hat, auch ein ähnliches Radar-Gerät dabei, die allerdings eine andere Auflösung haben und auch eine andere Tiefenauflösung. Ich glaube, die können nicht ganz so tief gucken, dafür haben sie eine bessere örtliche Auflösung. Also die können mehr unterschiedliche Schichten pro Zentimeter oder pro Meter jetzt sehen, aber dafür nicht ganz so tief gehen, während MARSIS hat weniger Auflösung in der Gesteinsschichten-Ebene als dafür tiefer.
Das ist also eine kollektive Erkenntnis, alle haben irgendwas gefunden und man ist sicher mittlerweile sehr sicher, dass das alles dort ist.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Mittlerweile hat auch zum Beispiel dieser Phoenix Lander, der konnte direkt mit so einer kleinen Schaufel eine Eisschicht aufkratzen.
Damit war es dann wirklich richtig bewiesen. Also man war sich nicht nur sicher aufgrund einer Beobachtung, sondern man hat es richtig in der Hand gehabt.
Wobei man natürlich auch über interferometrische Messungen, Spektroskopie, kann man natürlich auch feststellen, was für Elemente in der Atmosphäre rumfliegen und was für Elemente alles im Boden vorhanden ist. Dadurch, was für Strahlung das reflektiert von der Sonne oder ausstrahlt an Wärmestrahlung, da kann man ganz klare Linien sehen. Daher ist es für Wissenschaftler schon eindeutig, da braucht man nicht wirklich physikalisch hingehen und das in der Hand gehabt haben, dass man sich sicher ist, dass es da auch Wasser gibt.
Bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dem Instrument des MARSIS, also diese Radarantenne, die tief blicken lässt. 40 Meter lang?
Ja, 40 Meter lang.
Die muss man ja dann auch erstmal ausklappen. Also die würde ja nicht gleich 40 Meter lang in der Rakete ausgefallen gewesen sein.
Die ist eigentlich nicht 40 Meter lang, sondern es sind zwei Antennen, die 20 Meter lang sind. Eine zeigt eben vorwärts und eine rückwärts. Aber insgesamt gibt es einen 40 Meter langen Draht, der als Antenne verwendet werden kann. Die war vorher natürlich eingeklappt auf ungefähr 1,5 Meter kleine Stücke, die alle zusammengefaltet waren. Man muss sich das so vorstellen, das ist so ein hohles Rohr aus Kohlefaser oder Glasfaser, das an Gelenkpunkten immer einfach ein Loch hat und es ist zusammengeknickt. Dann wird es zusammengepresst, sodass es flach ist. Die Energie, die dabei gespeichert wird, das flach zu pressen, wurde dann später verwendet, um das wieder auszufalten. Man machte dann den Deckel auf und dann haben die ganzen flach gepressten Elemente sich wieder ausgedehnt. Dadurch hat sich das dann so ausgefaltet.
Das heißt, man brauchte keine Motoren oder sonst irgendwelche Sachen, sondern man hat einfach die Bewegungsenergie da einmal reingedrückt und dann nicht entweichen lassen und dann einfach Deckel auf. Dann kommt das wie so ein Kasperler an einer Spirale einfach rausgeschossen.
Genau, nur um den Deckel aufzumachen, hat man eben so pyrotechnische Bolzen, die dann gesprengt werden, damit der Deckel aufgeht.
Das ist also der Standard in der Raumfahrttechnik. Einfach alles wegspringen. Funktioniert gut, geht schnell, billig. Und dann hat sich das Ding automatisch in so eine lange... Ich meine, wenn es so aufgeht, dann kann es ja auch sein, dass es sich danach gleich wieder zusammenklappt. Rastet das dann ein?
Ja, das war nämlich auch das Problem. Ursprünglich war ja die gesamte Missionsphase von Mars Express nur auf zwei Jahre gedacht. Also Hauptmission ein Mars Jahr, ein Mars Jahr ist zwei Erdenjahre ungefähr, und dann noch eine extended, also eine erweiterte Missionsphase von einem weiteren Mars Jahr. Und eigentlich hätte dann schon von Anfang an bei der Ankunft an Mars diese Athenne ausgeklappt werden sollen, weil Teile von dieser Wissenschaft waren eben auch in der Hauptmission im Begriffen. Aber man hat dann bei Ankunft entschieden, weil es eine Studie gab, dass diese Ausfaltung der Antenne eventuell nicht klappen könnte oder dass die Antenne beim Ausklappen wieder zurückschwenken könnte und eventuell irgendwelche anderen lebenswichtigen Subsysteme verletzen könnte.
So wie die Solarpanele?
So wie die Solarpanele oder die Funkantenne, die den Funkkontakt mit der Erde aufrecht hält. Und dann hat man entschieden, das wird erst gemacht, wenn wir mit den ganzen anderen wissenschaftlichen Hauptzielen fertig sind. Und wenn das erste Mars vorbei ist, dann klappen wir erst die Marsantenne aus.
Die Studie ist dann erst während des Fluges erstellt worden?
Genau, das Ergebnis der Studie kam dann erst während des Fluges, während der Transferphase an. Und dann wurde die Entscheidung getroffen, dass das Ausklappen auf später verschoben wird.
Das überrascht mich ja, weil normalerweise doch eigentlich immer alles bis ins Letzte geprüft und getestet und durchdacht sein muss. Oder gab es dann irgendwie noch so einen späten Zweifler, der meinte, lasst uns lieber noch mal nachrechnen?
Ja, ich vermute mal, das war irgendjemand, der hat dann noch eine Computersimulation draus gemacht. Das hat man wahrscheinlich vorher alle schon im Labor getestet, aber ist schwierig, weil das alles in Schwerelosigkeit passiert. So eine 20-Meter-Antenne kann man jetzt auch schlecht in einem Parabelflug ausprobieren. Von daher war das ein bisschen kurzfristig.
Und hat es dann geklappt?
Ja, das hat dann geklappt. Allerdings konnte dann unsere Flugdynamikabteilung feststellen, nachdem das erste, das hat man also dann in Schritten gemacht. Erst mal den ersten 20-Meter-Arm ausklappen, dann den zweiten 20-Meter-Arm. Dann ist dann noch so ein dritter kleiner Arm, der senkrecht zu den zwei 20-Meter-Armen läuft, mit nur sieben Metern. Die hat man also ein nach dem anderen ausgeklappt. Nach dem ersten haben wir dann in dem Verhalten, wie der Satellit schwenkt, wie viel Energie der braucht, um einen Schwenkmanöver durchzuführen, konnte man feststellen, dass irgendwas nicht ganz stimmt, wie man es erwartet hat. Und dass wahrscheinlich ein Segment von dieser Antenne am Ende nicht ganz ausgeklappt war, sondern in so einem Winkel feststeckte. Da hat man dann verschiedene Sachen probiert, das vollständig auszuklappen. Und letztendlich hat es dann dadurch geklappt, dass man diesen Knick in die Sonne gerichtet hat. Und durch Aufheizen hat das dann geklappt. Wurde das aufgeschnalzt.
Das ist ja erstaunlich. Das heißt einerseits hat man natürlich so eine Erwartungsmessung, dass wenn man da jetzt so eine Unwucht eigentlich reinbringt, manöver macht, dass es sich dann eben nach der 10. Nachkommastelle wahrscheinlich so und so verhält.
Genau.
Und wenn das halt nicht kommt, es ist auch nicht so, dass es keine Kamera mit der man das hätte beobachten können.
Nein, leider nicht.
Das Ding kann sich nicht selber beobachten.
Man wünscht sich oft, da wären mehr Kameras an Bord, die alle möglichen Teile beobachten. Aber leider gab es da nur eine von die.
Verstehe, und die hat sich den Mars angeguckt.
Die war für den Beagle, um den Beagle anzugucken und zu sehen, wie der Beagle wegfliegt.
Genau, Beagle der Länder, da muss man natürlich noch drauf kommen. Bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dieser Antenne. Also das hat dann sozusagen gereicht. Kurz gesagt, eigentlich hat das Ding ganz gut funktioniert, nur das letzte Quäntchen hat gefehlt. Hat sich damit die Aussage dieser Studie in gewisser Hinsicht bewahrheitet? Also war das sozusagen das, was da als Szenario auch vorhergesagt wurde oder für möglich gehalten wurde?
Nein, die Studie, die wurde eigentlich damit widerlegt, weil es hat ja offensichtlich nicht zurückgeschnalzt und nichts kaputt gemacht, das lebenswichtig gewesen wäre.
Hurra! Okay, das ist also dieses Radar, was eben mit dieser Mega-Antenne im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes tief blicken lässt?
Genau, ja.
Was sind die anderen wichtigen Instrumente, die mit auf die Reise geblieben wurden?
Am wichtigsten ist natürlich noch Omega. Das ist eine Infrarot-Kamera, mit der man die Zusammensetzung des Oberflächengesteins feststellen kann. Mehr oder weniger wie eine normale Fotokamera, die nur in verschiedenen Infrarotkanälen das Licht aufhängt und nicht im Visuellen. Es hat auch einen visuellen Kanal, aber das ist eher so eine Wärmebildkamera.
Warum schaut man sich die Temperatur an? Ist es darum, wirklich herauszufinden?
Es geht nicht nur um die Temperatur, sondern es geht hauptsächlich darum, herauszufinden, wie stark verschiedene Frequenzen sichtbar sind. Dadurch kann man den Hinweis auf verschiedenste Moleküle und das Vorhandensein von verschiedensten Elementen auf der Oberfläche feststellen.
An der man wieder diese Spektroskopie machen kann.
Ein auch sehr wichtiges Instrument ist natürlich auch das HRSC, die High Resolution Stereo Camera. Die ist übrigens auch vom DLR hergestellt. Die kann hochauflösende Bilder von der Oberfläche machen, im sichtbaren Bereich. Das Besondere daran ist, die kann Stereobilder machen. Die hat verschiedene Kanäle. Die hat drei Farbkanäle, die ein bisschen vorwärts in der Flugbahn gucken. Und drei Farbkanäle, die nach unten, direkt senkrecht nach unten gucken. Und drei Farbkanäle, die schräg nach hinten gucken. Wenn man jetzt eine Stelle überfliegt, hat man da ein Bild, das von vorne auf die Stelle, auf der Oberfläche guckt und einmal von hinten, wenn man schon vorbei geflogen ist. Und die Bilder kann man dann zusammenrechnen. Da kann man dann ein 3D-Bild daraus rechnen. Das haben die meisten bestimmt schon mal gesehen. Die 3D-Bilder vom Mars. Es ist vor kurzem erst wieder von einem tollen Krater ein Bild veröffentlicht worden. Die sind wirklich atemberaubend. Das sieht man dann in Farbe, ungefähr so, wie es vielleicht auch für einen Astronauten dort aussehen würde.
Hätte man nicht diese Höhenvermessung auch gut mit dem Radar machen können?
Die kann man auch gut mit dem Radar machen. Die Höhenvermessung. Aber die 3D-Bilder, dass man das so stereoskopisch auch angucken kann, da gibt es nicht nur, man kann also auch so eine Art virtuellen Flug über die Oberfläche machen. Das macht die vom DLR immer ganz schön. Da kann man dann, wenn man die Information hat über die dreidimensionale Oberfläche und dann auch noch das überlagerte Farbkarte.
Also man hat halt nicht nur ein 3D-Modell, wie man es mit Radar machen könnte, sondern man weiß auch, wie es aussieht. Also man hat sozusagen richtig dreidimensionale Fotografie an der Stelle.
Genau. Außerdem ist natürlich das Radar, wie ich vorhin schon erwähnt hatte, es hat nicht so eine Oberflächenauflösung, sondern es hat mehr eine Tiefenauflösung. Also da könnte ich jetzt nur wirklich eine Aussage darüber treffen, wie hoch ist der Punkt genau unter mir. Aber nicht in einem zweidimensionalen Bereich, den ich mit einer Kamera angucke.
Deshalb mit der Kamera kriegt man auch überstehende Sachen mit.
Vor allem sieht man auch ein bisschen rechts und links und vorne und hinten. Und nicht nur genau den einen Punkt, über den ich gerade in dem Moment, wo ich das Signal geschickt habe, drüber geflogen bin.
Hier im Gespräch mit Tillmann Spohn, das ich hier vor einiger Zeit über die Mercure hatte, bemerkte er auch an, dass die HRSC-Kamera, das war nämlich gerade in der Woche der Landung von Curiosity, deswegen war das natürlich dann auch gleich ein Thema in der Sendung, merkte er auch an, dass die HRSC-Kamera ja auch die Bilder für diesen bemerkenswerten Trailer, der von der NASA produziert worden, vor der Landung verwendet wurden, dass das sozusagen dieses ganze Basismaterial ist, aus dem man jetzt diese hübschen Filmchen machen kann.
Ja, das ist so.
Und was heißt hochauflösend dann konkret? Also wie hochauflösend ist das jetzt? Was ist hoch?
Hochauflösend ist 10 Meter pro Pixel ungefähr, jetzt bei dieser Stereokamera. Das hängt aber allerdings auch von der Höhe ab, aus der man das Bild gemacht hat. Mars Express ist ja in einem hocheleiptischen Orbit, das heißt bei jedem Orbit fliegt er einmal ganz nah ran an den Mars, auf bis zu 300 Kilometer und dann auch wieder ganz weit weg auf eine Höhe von über 10.000 Kilometer. Das ist schon ein ziemlich gewaltiger Höhenunterschied, den der jedes Mal durchmacht. Die Bilder werden normalerweise immer so nah wie möglich an der Oberfläche aufgenommen, also so 300 Kilometer. Aber im Laufe der Zeit hat sich der Orbit auch geändert. Mal war das auch schon tiefer, bei ungefähr 250 Kilometer. Die höchste Auflösung liegt etwa bei 10 Meter pro Pixel. Aber es kann auch mal 20 Meter pro Pixel sein, je nachdem, in welcher Höhe das Bild aufgenommen wurde. Dann hat die Kamera auch noch einen super hoch auflösenden Kanal. Der kann allerdings keine 3D-Bilder erzeugen. Die kann dann bis zu 2 Meter pro Pixel Bilder machen.
Das ist schon relativ viel, wenn man aus 300 Kilometern Entfernung was fotografiert. Das ist auch alles im Einsatz.
Also die SRC-Kamera, dieser Super Resolution Channel, der ist im Moment nicht mehr im Einsatz. Oder noch nicht wieder einsatzbereit. Weil da gab es ein kleines Problem mit unserem Massenspeicher. Da mussten dann einige Instrumentkonfigurationen an Bord geändert werden. Und darunter hat unter anderem auch dieser Super Resolution Channel gelitten. Weil eine Stromversorgung an der jetzigen Konfiguration leider nicht angeschlossen ist.
Das heißt, man musste auf so ein Backup-System ausweichen.
Genau.
Und das ist nicht im selben Maße mit allem anderen vernetzt wie das Original.
Das liegt auch unter anderem daran, dass es eine Express-Mission ist. Und alles eben schnell zusammengebaut worden ist. Und manche Sachen auch in letzter Minute noch eingebaut worden sind. Dieser Super Resolution Channel wurde nachträglich noch mit angebaut. Und der ist eben dann auch nicht hundertprozentig kreuzverkabelt worden.
Weil dafür nicht die Zeit war?
Weil die Zeit nicht dafür war, genau.
Hektisch, hektisch. Aber man kann ja nicht irgendwann starten. Man muss ja auch genau das richtige Fenster treffen, weil sonst ist der Mars ja wieder weg.
Genau, gerade mit diesen Hohmann-Transfers, da kann man nicht irgendwann losfliegen. Da muss man genau im richtigen Moment starten. Weil sonst würde die Reise bei weitem länger als sechs Monate dauern.
Dann muss man wieder zwei Jahre warten, bis der Mars wieder eingeholt wurde. Oder ein wieder Erde ist schon da.
Genau, er wird von der Erde eingeholt.
Vielleicht noch mal zu dem Orbit. Ich erinnere mich auch gerade wieder, Venus Express hat ja auch so eine hoch-elliptische Bahn. Da ist es glaube ich noch ein bisschen extremer. Wobei es bei Venus Express so ist, dass man immer am Nordpol nah dran ist. Und sich das nicht bewegt. Aber der Orbit von Mars Express ist zwar immer eine Ellipse, aber der Punkt, wo man dem Mars am nächsten ist, ist sozusagen immer woanders.
Der wandert. Mars Express ist auch in einer polaren Umlaufbahn. Das heißt, wenn man den Mars durchschneiden würde, in der Ebene, in der sich Mars Express immer um den Mars rum bewegt, dann wäre der Pol ganz nah an diesem Schnittpunkt dran. Aber der Punkt, wo Mars Express immer am nächsten an Mars dran ist, der wandert immer so rum. Vom Nordpol zum Südpol zum Nordpol zum Südpol. Das Ding eiert. Genau, das eiert.
Wie lange braucht er für einmal rum?
Ungefähr neun Monate.
Wie lange braucht er für einen Orbit?
Für einen Orbit sieben Stunden.
Sieben Stunden?
Genau.
Und nach diesen sieben Stunden ist er so gefühlt, wie weit mit seinem nächsten Punkt weiter marschiert? So ein bisschen oder ganz woanders? Ganz bisschen.
Also der Breitengrad ändert sich nur ganz bisschen. Aber der Längengrad ändert sich natürlich gehörig, weil der Mars selbst dreht sich genauso schnell wie die Erde etwa. Also der Mars-Tage ist etwas länger als der Erdentag.
40 Minuten mehr sind es glaube ich.
Ist gut möglich, ja. Und deswegen die sieben Stunden, da passt das nicht. Das gibt dann keine Resonanz wirklich. Also wir haben schon vorher, wurden Resonanz-Orbits geflogen mit verschiedenen Resonanzparametern. Also nach wie vielen Tagen oder nach wie vielen Orbits sich die gleiche Stelle wiederholt, über die man drüber fliegt. Aber mittlerweile haben wir einen sogenannten Free-Drift-Orbit. Da wird also einfach geflogen, wie es von der Physik her kommt. Da muss man dann auch nicht den Orbit ständig nachkorrigieren.
Man überlässt es sozusagen ein bisschen dem Zufall oder der freien Gestaltung durch die Kräfte, die dort eben wirken. Aber nach Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung kommt man dann halt eigentlich überall mal auch irgendwann vorbei. So dass man das gar nicht groß planen muss. Das heißt, sieben Stunden einmal rum, man kommt dann immer wieder irgendwo anders näher ran, dort wird dann fotografiert, Blitzlicht, Gewitter. Sozusagen der Mars-Spotlight. Und dann setzt man das daraus zusammen.
Das kann man aber relativ gut im Voraus berechnen, wo der Satellit wann sein wird. Und die Wissenschaftler, die nehmen das dann auch her, um schon teilweise vier Monate im Voraus zu planen, wo sie jetzt welches Bild machen wollen.
Der Länderbiegel ist so ein bisschen in Vergessenheit geraten. Man kann es ja gleich sagen, nicht so unrecht, weil es ja misslungen ist. Das heißt, es gab nicht nur den eigentlichen Satelliten, der jetzt nach wie vor erfolgreich den Mars umrundet, sondern man war ganz kühn und hat gesagt, wir wollen jetzt auch noch was abwerfen. Was war denn der eigentliche Plan? Und was ist schiefgegangen?
Der eigentliche Plan war, dass man eben ein Landungssystem hat, das unter anderem dazu dient, die Erfahrung zu sammeln und die Technologie auf den Prüfstand zu stellen, dass man auf den Mars landen kann. Und zum anderen natürlich auch direkt aus erster Hand Gesteinsproben zu haben und den Boden zu untersuchen. Der hat ja auch unter anderem einen kleinen Bohrer dabei, der Beagle. Das war so eine kleine Scheibe, die dann so vier kreisrunde Solar-Paneele ausgeklappt hätte, wenn sie sicher gelandet wäre. Und dann hätte sich so ein kleiner robotischer Arm ausgefaltet und mit einer Kamera dran und dem Bohrer und so weiter. Und das hat halt leider die Landung leider nicht geklappt. Eigentlich weiß man gar nicht genau, welcher Teil der Landung nicht so ganz genau geklappt hat, weil der Beagle hat ja während, sobald er von Mars Express abgekoppelt war, war kein Funkkontakt vorgesehen, vom Missionsdesign her, bis zur erfolgreichen Landung.
Das heißt, man hat das Ding abgeworfen und seitdem war nichts wieder von ihm zu hören.
Genau, da gibt es noch diese kleine Kamera, die wir jetzt auch als Mars Webcam verwenden, die sogenannte VMC. Die hat dann auch Bilder von dem Beagle gemacht, nachdem er abgekoppelt war. Noch im Flug, bis er dann auch zu einem kleinen Pünchen verschwunden ist. Das war das Letzte, was man von dem Beagle gesehen und gehört hat.
Also vermutlich wird er schon auf der Oberfläche angekommen sein, weil es sehr viele andere Optionen gab es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Möglicherweise etwas zu schnell angekommen und dabei kaputt gegangen.
Schade.
Es gibt da eine Reihe von Dingen, die fehlgeschlagen sein können. Es können die Fallschirme nicht aufgegangen sein. Es kann sein, dass von den Ballons, der hat ja so ein Ballon-Polster-Landesystem gehabt, dass da welche nicht aufgeblasen sind. Aber das kann man alles nicht nachvollziehen.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen schade, wenn man dann noch nicht mal weiß, woran es jetzt eigentlich Gelegenheit ist. Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist ja Mars Express an sich eine sehr erfolgreiche Mission geworden.
Ja, durch die vielen dreidimensionalen, hochauflösenden Fotos, die man auch sehr oft sieht. Und außerdem, weil eben auch Wasser nachgewiesen wurde von dem Satelliten.
Also für eine erste Mission schon mal gar nicht so wenig. Und vor allem lebt das Ding ja auch immer noch. Genau, dass es noch nicht vorbei ist.
Nur für vier Jahre vorgesehen war. Jetzt pflegen wir mittlerweile schon über neun Jahre. Ist das eigentlich schon eine ganz gute Leistung.
Es gibt ja nicht nur den Mars, sondern der Mars hat ja, was viele nicht so, glaube ich, immer so auf dem Zeiger haben, hat ja auch noch einen Mond.
Genau.
Phobos?
Da hat er eigentlich noch zwei Monde.
Zwei?
Phobos und Deimos.
Ach ja, richtig, das ist ja noch einer.
Der Deimos ist noch kleiner. Er ist noch kleiner als der Phobos.
Das sind eigentlich nicht so richtige Monde, wenn man das so als Erdenmensch mal sagen darf. Also so ein richtiger Mond, ist das ja nicht.
Da war ja noch nicht mal einer drauf.
Genau. Ja, der scheint sich da auch sehr zu wehren.
Ja, Russland wollte ja da eine Landungssphäre hinschicken. Die hat es leider nicht weiter hinaus, über den Erdorbit hinaus geschafft. Die ist leider wieder zurück auf die Erde gefallen.
Die russische Pechsträne mit dem Mars hält leider an.
Leider.
Spielt der Phobos für Mars Express in irgendeiner Form eine Rolle?
Ja, Phobos spielt eine sehr große Rolle für Mars Express. Der Phobos fliegt auf einer Laufbahn von ungefähr 4000 Kilometer Höhe über der Mars-Oberfläche am Equator. Mars Express fliegt ja zwischen 300 und 10.000 Kilometer. Und dadurch, dass sich eben der nächste Punkt, also das Perizentrum, immer so zwischen Nord- und Südpol herum dreht, kommt die Umlaufbahn auch öfters mal in die Quere mit der Umlaufbahn von Phobos. Allerdings muss man sich jetzt so vorstellen, dass der Phobos ja nicht immer an jedem Punkt in seiner Umlaufbahn gleichzeitig und Mars Express auch nicht. Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sich die beide treffen, ist relativ gering. Aber es gibt dann doch immer alle sechs Monate eine Gelegenheit für die Wissenschaftler, ein schönes, hochauflösendes Bild vom Phobos zu machen, weil man da relativ nahe rankommt.
Wie nah ist man dann?
Also das nächste war, soweit ich weiß, schon mal unter 100 Kilometer.
Unter 100?
Unter 100 Kilometer.
Und dann kann man auch mit allen Instrumenten draufgehen? Kann man den so drehen, dass er dann alles auf...?
Auf diejenigen, die üblicherweise auch die Mars-Oberfläche fotografieren, die kann man auch alle auf den Phobos verwenden. Also HRSC, Omega, PFS, MARSIS, mit Radar macht man da auch was. Die können alle verwendet werden.
Ich sehe gerade so ein paar Fotos, das kann ich jetzt nicht ausreichend beschreiben, aber es sieht so ein bisschen aus wie eine Kartoffel.
Ja, das ist die häufigste Aussage, die man so hört. Der Phobos sieht aus wie eine Kartoffel. Passt, das stimmt.
Es sieht auch ein bisschen aus wie so ein Stein, aber ist halt so ein bisschen kartoffelartig geformt. Also es ist wirklich mehr so ein Trabant als ein richtiger Mond.
Der hat auch ziemlich viele Krater. Manche sind sogar so groß, dass die Oberfläche so verformt ist, weil der Krater schon fast halb so groß ist wie der Mond selber.
Sprich, Mars Express liefert so einen konstanten Datenstrom, seit es dort herumfliegt. Und wie lange geht das noch weiter?
Wovon hängt das jetzt ab?
Im Wesentlichen lebt ihr von den Solarzellen. Das ist die einzige Energiequelle.
Genau, es gibt auch noch andere Energiequellen. Und zwar gibt es auch noch Treibstoff an Bord, der regelmäßig dazu verwendet werden muss, um die Schwungräder zu entladen. Also der Mars Express bewegt sich, der rotiert, um jetzt ein bestimmtes Instrument an eine bestimmte Stelle zu zeigen oder auch um die Funkantenne zur Erde zu richten. Der bewegt sich da mit Schwungrädern. Das funktioniert über das Impulserhaltungsgesetz. Ich drehe ein Schwungrad an, mach das schneller. Damit dreht sich Mars Express in die andere Richtung, im Gegensatz zu dem Schwungrad. Da sind vier Stück drin. Damit kann man das komplette Raumfahrzeug in alle Richtungen steuern. Allerdings gibt es äußere Einflüsse, die jetzt versuchen, den Satelliten mal hier hin und mal da hin zu drehen. Das wird dann von den Schwungrädern ausgeglichen. Die nehmen dadurch Energie auf von außen, die man wieder zurücksetzen muss. Die haben natürlich nicht unendlich viel Kapazität. Die können nicht unendlich schnell, die sollen auch nicht zu langsam laufen. Dafür braucht man regelmäßig ein kleines Manöver. Man muss dann mit den Steuerdüsen gegenhalten, wenn man die Schwungräder wieder in einem bequemen Drehzahlbereich fährt. Verstehe. Das ist das eine.
Was ist das für ein Ereignis? Ein Vorbeiflug an Phobos? Erzeugt das solche Energien?
Phobos eher nicht. Wir fliegen jeden Orbit ziemlich nah an Mars vorbei. Das erzeugt eine der Hauptenergien. Das andere ist, die Solarzellen kriegen ständig einen Druck von dem Sonnenwind ab. Die ganzen Photonen, die von der Sonne ausgehen, drücken auf die Solarzellen drauf. Da die Achse nicht ganz durch das Massenzentrum hindurchgeht, die Aufhängungsachse der Solarzellen, gibt es da einen Hebelarm, das drückt das Raumfahrzeug immer ein bisschen nach hinten weg. Diese Energie wird dann auch von den Rädern aufgenommen. Dafür brauchen wir ab und zu jeden Tag einmal ungefähr ein bisschen was, ganz wenig, nicht mal ein halbes Gramm Treibstoff und das ist also definitiv eine Ressource, die irgendwann mal eventuell...
Nicht mal ein halbes Gramm?
Nicht mal ein halbes Gramm, ja.
Wow, so fein kann man das dosieren?
So fein kann man das dosieren, ja.
Das ist ja Raketenwissenschaft, ist das ja. Immer wieder faszinierend, diese Details. Vielleicht noch ein anderes Detail, auch wenn ich dann immer den kleinen Problemen und gescheiterten Details auf den Leib rücke. Aber ich finde das eigentlich immer am faszinierendsten. Ich meine, wenn alles klappt, ist es eigentlich fast langweilig. Aber wenn mal was schiefgeht, dann ist ja wirklich da auch die ganze Hirnmasse des Teams gefragt, um dann einfach dem entgegenzugehen. Es sind ja noch ein paar andere Sachen nicht so gut gelaufen. Du hast vorhin das schon erwähnt mit dem Massenspeicher, was dann Auswirkungen hatte, unter anderem dann eben für die Stromversorgung oder die Datenzuleitung von dem HSRC-Instrument. Kannst du noch mal so ein bisschen beschreiben, was da jetzt eigentlich das Problem war und wie komplex die Auswirkungen auf das Gesamtsystem dann sind?
Ja, und zwar wir hatten unser Massenspeicher, der hat so eine Controller-Chip, der die Speicherbänke dann anspricht. Und der hat plötzlich nicht mehr funktioniert und dann wurde festgestellt, dass da irgendwo nicht der richtige Strom geflossen ist. Also so viel ich weiß, ist da irgendwo weniger Strom geflossen als eigentlich erwartet. Das heißt, wurde festgestellt, irgendwo ist da wahrscheinlich von der Hardware her was nicht mehr ganz in Ordnung. Das hat zwar dann wieder funktioniert, nachdem man das neu gestartet hat, also Strom abgeschaltet, wieder neu starten, wieder alles von vorne aufspielen, die ganzen Dateien und so weiter. Aber es ist dann nach kurzer Zeit wieder was passiert und man hat dann entschieden, dass wir eben auf den redundanten Controller zurückgreifen, der die gleichen Speicherbänke ansprechen kann, der eben auf dieser redundanten B-Seite ist. Das hat wiederum zur Folge gehabt, dass man einige der Instrumente auch auf die B-Seite umschalten musste, weil die nicht kreuzverkabelt waren.
Das heißt, man war sozusagen zwangsläufig gezwungen, das Backup eines Instruments zu nehmen, was eigentlich gar nicht kaputt war, damit es seine Daten noch abliefern kann. Verstehe.
Und dann hat uns der zweite Controller allerdings auch noch Probleme bereitet. Und so haben wir festgestellt, dass die Kommunikation zwischen dem Hauptcomputer und dem Controller ab und zu mal einen kleinen Aussetzer haben kann. Und der Hauptcomputer reagiert da ziemlich allergisch drauf. Der bringt dann das Raumfahrzeug sofort in einen Safe Mode. Wenn der eine Anfrage an den Computer stellt, gib mir mal den nächsten Befehl, den du gespeichert hast. An den Massenspeicher. Unsere gesamte Befehlsliste. Das Raumfahrzeug muss ja ferngesteuert sein, wegen der Zeitdauer zwischen Erde und Mars. Das muss alles genau programmiert sein. Das heißt, wir geben eine Zeit, eine Timeline, geben wir vor. So was wie ein Fahrplan. Genau alles nach minutiös und sekundengenau geplant ist, welche Befehle wann ablaufen müssen. Der Speicher, der diese ganzen Befehle speichert, der befindet sich auch auf dem Massenspeicher. Der Hauptcomputer muss dann eben vom Massenspeicher immer wieder fragen, gib mir mal die nächsten paar Befehle, die ich jetzt gleich ausführen muss. Wenn der da mal nicht rechtzeitig antwortet, der Massenspeicher, dann sagt der Hauptcomputer, hier ist irgendwas ganz faul. Ich kann so nicht weitermachen, weil ich nicht sicher sein kann, dass alles sicher abläuft, dass ich alle Befehle gekriegt habe, die vom Boden her einprogrammiert worden sind. Und wenn da einer fehlt, könnte er theoretisch ein gravierendes Problem zur Folge haben. Also schalte dann erstmal auf Sicherheitsmodus und sagt, ja, irgendwie, irgendwas stimmt nicht mit meinen Komponenten. Und ich schalte jetzt den kompletten Satellit in einen Sicherheitspark-Modus. Es hat immer wieder auch zur Folge dieser Safe-Mode, dass eine nicht zu vernachlässigende Menge Treibstoff verbraucht wird, weil der erstmal sagt, ja, Moment mal, vielleicht ist ja nicht nur das kaputt, sondern es könnte auch noch was anderes kaputt sein. Also erstmal zurückgehen auf Null, auf Anfang. Und ich fange von vorne an. Ich suche erstmal, wo ist die Sonne. Dann stelle ich fest, dann checke ich, ob meine Sternen-Tracker, meine Star-Tracker noch funktionieren. Und dann suche ich mal die Erde. Und dann versuche ich Verbindung mit der Erde aufzunehmen. Und das wird aber alles erstmal auch ohne Schwungräder gemacht. Die werden dann auch im Laufe dieser Erdsuche erst eingeschaltet. Und dabei wird dann auch einiges an Treibstoff verwendet.
Jeder Fehler verbraucht Treibstoff und kostet auch viel Zeit, weil wenn er sich sozusagen selbstständig erstmal der Sonne zuwendet, nehme ich jetzt mal an, damit irgendwie auch genug Energie da ist, und dann mit der Erde funkt, das dauert ja auch alles.
Genau, eben. Ja, und dann haben wir uns entschlossen, dass...
Wie oft hat er das jetzt gemacht dann? Das ist dann am laufenden Meter aufgetreten.
Im August ist das erste Problem mit der A-Seite von dem Speicher aufgetreten. Und dann im September und Oktober sind die Probleme mit der B-Seite aufgetreten. Und seitdem haben wir uns dann eben entschieden, also es waren dann dreimal, dreimal war das Safe Mode, und wir haben uns dann entschieden, wir verlassen uns jetzt nicht mehr auf den Kommandospeicher, in den Massenspeicher, sondern wir nehmen eine so eine Art kurzes RAM-Speichergedächtnis von dem Hauptcomputer her, um dort eine geringere Menge von vorprogrammierten Befehlen zu speichern. Allerdings mussten wir dann eben schauen, dass der auch immer wieder schön aufgefüllt wird und rechtzeitig aufgefüllt wird.
Wie viel geringer als...
Ja, vorher in dem Marsenspeicher hatten wir Platz für 3000 vorprogrammierte Befehle und in dem RAM-Speicher von dem Hauptcomputer ist nur noch Platz für 117. Also von 3000 auf 117. Und das Problem wurde dann durch einen Cleveren.
Wie weit kommen wir mit 117 Kommandos? Wie umfangreich sind diese Kommandos? Wie viele Kommandos müssen ausgeführt werden, um so ein Tagesprogramm abzuleisten?
Also die Kommandos haben natürlich auch unterschiedliche Aufgaben. Also zum Beispiel ein Teil der Kommandos steuert die Kommunikation, wann die Antenne ein- und ausgeschaltet wird, also wann der Sender für die Erdkommunikation ein- und ausgeschaltet wird. Dann wann Daten von dem Massenspeicher zur Erde geschickt werden. Wenn irgendwelche Flugmanöver, Schwenkmanöver durchgeführt werden. Das ist relativ aufwendig, das braucht relativ viele Befehle. Wenn man ganz genau, Sekunde für Sekunde, muss der Satellit ganz genau wissen, in welche Richtung er jetzt mit welcher Achse zeigen muss. Und wann zum Beispiel auch so eine Schwungradentladung vorgenommen werden muss. Wann die Solar-Panele sich alles anbrotieren müssen.
Sie haben alle eine unterschiedliche Komplexität, aber im Mittel. Um so einen Tag durchzustehen, so ein Mars-Tag, oder auch ein Erdentag, ist ja fast das gleiche. Was verbraucht der? Braucht er so 10 oder 100 oder 2.000?
Momentan, mit all unseren Verbesserungen, schaffen wir es mit etwa 2.000 bis 3.000 pro Woche.
Das heißt, man muss am Tag mehrere Male aktualisieren, damit immer wieder was zu tun ist?
Ja, allerdings das Aktualisieren, das nehmen wir dann auch wieder aus dem Massenspeicher vor. Nur, wir haben das Konzept so geändert, dass der Hauptcomputer nicht selber dafür verantwortlich ist, welche Befehle und in welche Geschwindigkeit er Befehle vom Massenspeicher nachlädt, sondern er kriegt immer von uns vordefinierte Pakete, die zwischen zwei Kommandos und auch bis zu 70 Kommandos groß sein können. Und auch von uns vorberechnete Zeitpunkte, wann die geladen werden müssen. Und das ermöglicht uns dann jetzt genauso wieder die Qualitätsmöglichkeiten zu machen wie vorher.
So softwaretechnisch ausgesucht, ihr habt ja auch so ein Transaktionsmodell umgesetzt, ihr holt euch sozusagen immer zusammenhängende Schritte, die sozusagen dann auch wirklich vollständig alle gemacht werden müssen, so weit rüber. Und wenn es dann im Rahmen ist, dann kann man auch sagen, ok, führ das jetzt mal aus, dann fehlt da halt keiner.
Genau, dann fehlt da nichts. Und wenn jetzt mal eine von diesen Dateien, die jetzt so ein Paket beinhaltet, wenn die nicht komplett geladen werden kann, dann ist das zwar schade, dann funktioniert, hat halt irgendeine wissenschaftliche Beobachtung nicht stattgefunden, oder es wurde der Funksender nicht eingeschaltet, oder irgendwie sowas. Aber geht nicht in Safe Mode. Es geht nicht in Safe Mode. Und wir wissen, wie wir das Problem glatt bügeln können, oder es geht weiter.
Jetzt ist da ja eine Menge los am Mars. Das ist ja jetzt nicht so wie, was weiß ich, wo es gerade wenig los ist. Venus, ja, also sehr viel fliegt nicht herum. Nur beim Mars ist ja richtig Alarm. Also da sind allein zwei Fahrzeuge jetzt auf der Mars-Oberfläche noch unterwegs. Es gibt von der NASA noch zwei weitere Satelliten, die den Mars umfliegen. Den MRO, Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter, und dann, wie heißt der andere Mars Odyssey? Mars Odyssey. Wie ist da, also inwiefern betrifft einen das, dass sozusagen noch andere Missionen da sind? Wie sehr tauscht man sich da mit der NASA aus? Macht da jeder so sein Ding? Oder stimmt man sich da auch in irgendeiner Form auch ab und übernimmt gegenseitig Sachen? Es gab ja jetzt auch so gerade um die Landung von Curiosity. Würde mich auch mal interessieren, wie das gelaufen ist da. Viel Zusammenarbeit. Was hat das für einen Einfluss?
Ja, also es gibt schon Abstimmung. Und das findet auf verschiedenen Ebenen statt. Normalerweise macht jeder sein Ding. Aber wir verwenden zum Beispiel auch die Bodenstationen der NASA aus dem Deep Space Network, DSN, der NASA. Die bekommen wir teilweise zur Verfügung gestellt. In der Woche drei bis vier Kontakte jedenfalls haben wir über solche DSN-Antennen mit unserem Mars Express. Da ist es teilweise so, dass wir zwar zuhören können, was unser Satellit zu uns sagt, aber wir können keine Kommandos schicken, weil die gleiche Antenne zur gleichen Zeit gerade für ein anderes NASA-Raumfahrzeug, sei es ein Lander oder ein Fahrzeug oder ein Orbiter zu sein, aber jedenfalls die sogenannte Uplink-Kapazität, um jetzt Befehle hochzuschicken, da kann immer nur einer. Da kann nicht mehrere gleichzeitig sprechen.
Stau auf der Mars-Autobahn.
Aber zuhören kann man mehreren gleichzeitig. Da gibt es verschiedene Verschlüsselungen oder Kodierungsverfahren, sodass es verschiedene Kanäle gibt, die sich nicht in die Quere kommen.
Senden ist schwierig.
Senden ist schwierig, da geht immer nur einer.
Gut, aber ihr verwendet ja auch genauso die ESA-Systeme, das S-Track etc.
Da haben wir immer volle Sendekapazität. Also das ist das eine, das beeinflusst uns eher passiv, weil wir kriegen die Stationen von der NASA, von dem DSN-Netzwerk schon so zugewiesen in dem Modus. Das ist dann auch nicht immer so. Meistens haben wir schon Sendekapazität, aber manchmal passiert das eben, dass eine Station dann die Sendekapazität nicht hat. Dann das andere ist, von der Flugbahn her kommen wir uns nicht in die Quere. Die sind viel niedriger als Mars Express. Die fliegen in Orbits um die 200 Kilometer und die fliegen kreisrunde Orbits, keine elliptischen. Das heißt, da gibt es keine Konflikte. Aber jetzt zum Beispiel mit den Rovern, da haben wir ab und zu mit unserer Lander-Antenne, die eigentlich für unseren Beagle mit an Bord ist, um mit dem Beagle zu kommunizieren. Da haben wir ab und zu in so einer Zusammenarbeit mit der NASA Funkkontakte mit den Rovern. Und das ist gedacht, um jetzt eben zum Beispiel, wenn die NASA ein Problem mit ihrem Orbiter hat und die keinen Funkkontakt mit ihren Rovern aufnehmen können, dann ist das gesamte Malwerk quasi schon in Bewegung. Dann weiß jeder schon, wie er das machen muss, um jetzt über Mars Express einen Funkkontakt zu dem Rover herzustellen.
Hat das auch schon stattgefunden, oder ist das jetzt nur so eine theoretische Vorbereitung?
Nein, nein, das hat schon stattgefunden. Das hat auch schon vor der Curiosity-Landung stattgefunden, dass wir mit Opportunity und Spirit ab und zu mal kurze Funkkontakte hatten. Das war dann immer etwa so alle sechs Monate mal ein kurzer Funkkontakt.
So wie bei Star Trek, so die großen Großfrequenzen.
Das ist auch nicht mehr als so ein Hallo.
Man hat schon mal getestet, man versteht sich.
Man spricht die gleiche Sprache. Und man weiß, wie man jetzt einen Kontakt aufbauen könnte, einen ernsthaften Kontakt, falls mal was schiefgehen sollte.
Schon so ein bisschen Internet eigentlich.
Ja, ist schon ein bisschen so was wie ein Mars-Internet. Ja, mit Curiosity hatten wir auch schon Funkverbindungen. Wir wurden sogar auch schon Test-Commandos zu Curiosity hingeschickt von Mars Express aus. Und bei der Landung natürlich von Curiosity, jetzt habe ich ja vorhin schon erzählt, wie das bei dem Beagle gelaufen ist, dass man während der Landung keinen Funkkontakt hatte mit dem Lander und dadurch auch nicht genau weiß, wann und in welcher Flugphase was schiefgelaufen ist. Und dabei haben wir eben der NASA auch mitgeholfen, bei dem atmosphärischen Eintritt in die Mars-Atmosphäre und bei der kompletten Landesequenz immer auf der Frequenz von Curiosity mitzuhören. Zwar haben wir also nicht wirklich Datenempfang, aber zumindest die Funkfrequenz abgehört. Und da gibt es dann auch so verschiedene Töne, die da gesendet werden, um verschiedene Flugphasen zu markieren. Und das wurde alles da mitgehört. Und sozusagen auch als ein Sicherheitskanal, falls jetzt einer von den NASA-Orbitern nicht so wie geplant die Landung mitverfolgen konnte.
Die Landung war ja jetzt relativ reibungslos. Aber wäre jetzt was schiefgegangen, hätte auch Mars Express gegebenenfalls zur Analyse beitragen können.
Genau, man hätte dann quasi noch einen dritten Blickwinkel zusätzlich zu dem Odyssey und dem MRO gehabt. Um jetzt genau zu analysieren, was denn wirklich schief gelaufen wäre.
War denn das jetzt so getimt, dass wirklich alle drei Orbiter da auch in der Nähe waren?
Ja, das wurde sogar dann schon auch lange im Vorfeld, wurde unser Orbit so angepasst, dass das dann auch genau zu dem richtigen Zeitpunkt Mars Express über die Landestelle drüberfliegt.
Also das ist ja schon ein recht umfangreiches Maß an Koordination, was man da auch machen muss. Wie weiträumig wurde das im Vorfeld geplant? Ist das so kurz vorher so?
Da wurde schon mehr als ein Jahr vor dem Start des Curiosity Rovers mit der NASA Verhandlungen geführt, in welchem Ausmaß man jetzt Support zur Verfügung stellt und wie es genau ablaufen soll, die ganzen Details. Und mussten dann solche Daten ausgetauscht werden, eben wie was wird die Landestelle sein. Man hat also wirklich auf unserer Seite bis zu dem Zeitpunkt gewartet, dass die NASA jetzt endgültig die Landestelle aussucht, weil die hatten ja auch drei Kandidaten zur Verfügung, welche Landestelle das genau sein wird. Und wir mussten eben dann warten, bis die das genau ausgewählt haben, um jetzt genau zu wissen, wie der Orbit angepasst werden muss und wie lange im Voraus am besten schon der Orbit angepasst werden muss, damit wir dann zum richtigen Zeitpunkt an der richtigen Stelle sind.
Und wann ist die letzte Entscheidung gefallen dann? Wie viel Zeit war da noch bis zur Landung? Bis es dann wirklich klar war, wir wollen jetzt hier in den Gale-Krater an die Stelle?
Das war so weit, ich weiß sogar, das war schon noch bevor der gestartet ist. Da haben die das noch ausgesucht.
Okay, da waren sie sich schon ein bisschen...
Zwei, drei Monate vorher.
Obwohl man es auch noch auf den letzten Metern gegebenenfalls hätte, vielleicht nicht auf den letzten Metern, aber auf den letzten Teil, hätte er auch noch justieren können. Aber man hat sich dafür entschlossen und dann den Plan auch nicht mehr geändert.
Ja, da hätte man auch noch ein bisschen drehen können, aber...
Nicht mehr viel.
Das war schon echt eine bemerkenswerte Punktleitung. Ich hatte ja mit dem Thema Spohnen auch schon darüber gesprochen, wie das so ist, wenn auf internationaler Ebene so ein Projekt ist, was auch so viel Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt. Ich meine, werdet ja hier dann sicherlich auch alle mit großer Anspannung daran teilgenommen haben. Absolut. Und dann aber eben auch noch aktiv sozusagen mitmessend. Also jetzt mal so ein bisschen beschreiben, wie der Tag für euch so gelaufen ist.
Gut, hier haben sich die meisten schon dann, auch obwohl es in relativ früher Stunde war, schon vor Ort eingefunden. Das war ja, die Punktlandung war um 5 Uhr 18 nach internationaler Zeit. Genau. Das heißt, es war hier so um 7 Uhr 2 Stunden. War Sommerzeit, genau. Und natürlich hatten wir sich vorher schon, weil die ganze Anflugphase und das alles passiert ja auch schon vor der Landung. Und deswegen hatten wir sich also schon so um ungefähr um halb 6 oder so haben sich welche hier eingefunden. Und dann wurde hier ESA TV mitverfolgt und NASA TV in verschiedenen Kontrollräumen. Im Hauptkontrollraum war natürlich auch viel los, da war viel Presse. Deswegen war das Team da nicht, da waren nur ein, zwei Leute vom Team im Hauptkontrollraum mit, um jetzt da nicht zu viele Leute da rumstehen zu haben. Aber wir haben auch noch unseren eigenen Kontrollraum. Von da haben also auch verschiedene ESOG-Mitarbeiter das mitverfolgt. Aber gleichzeitig mitmessen ging natürlich bei uns dann nicht, weil Mars Express vom Design her nicht gleichzeitig mit dem Lander-Funkgerät was aufnehmen kann und es gleichzeitig zur Erde weiter schicken kann. Das muss erst aufnehmen, abspeichern und dann sich mit der Funkantenne zur Erde hin drehen und dann alles wieder zur Erde senden. Das hat dann eben etwa eine Dreiviertelstunde oder so gedauert, bis das dann letztendlich an der Erde ankam.
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt wusste man ja schon, dass es geklappt hat.
Da wusste man schon von der NASA, dass alles geklappt hat, genau. Da hat man dann aber noch interessante Daten filtern können, also wie jetzt die Doppelfrequenz sich verändert hat während der Eintrittsphase.
Und jetzt kann man demnächst schöne, hochauflösende Fotos auch schießen, wenn man dann mal zufällig über Curiosity schwebt. Oder hat das sogar schon stattgefunden?
Das weiß ich gar nicht, ob das schon stattgefunden hat. Aber die Auflösung ist vermutlich von der Mars Express HRSC-Kamera nicht hoch genug, um da jetzt was zu erkennen. Weil der Curiosity ist ja gerade mal 3-4 Meter groß.
Aber dann ist es dann vom MRO?
Der MRO hat eine viel höhere Auflösung. Der hat ungefähr 10 bis 20 Zentimeter Auflösung.
Das sind also von dem die Fotos gewesen. Weil man sieht das ja jetzt schon netter, diese Landestelle sogar mit den Wegspuren.
Die haben ja auch unmittelbar ein Foto von dem Curiosity noch am Fallschirm gemacht. Dann kurz danach ein Foto von der Landestelle mit den ganzen abgesprengten Teilen. Also der Skycrane und die Fallschirme und der Hitzeschild. Und die Rückenschale. Also alle diese Teile, die da während dem Flug abgesprengt worden sind. Die hat er alle auf einen Blick getroffen. Die haben mir dann so ein schönes Foto rumgeschickt. Crime Scene haben wir das genannt.
Erstaunlich. Also nicht nur, dass man jetzt so ein Monster-Fahrzeug da irgendwie hingeschossen bekommt und mit einer verhältnismäßig spektakulären Landung landen lässt. Nein, er filmt das dann auch noch alles mit. Und man kann auch noch irgendwie hochauflösende Fotos davon bekommen. Und das Ganze auf einem Planeten, der so weit weg ist, dass es alleine eine Viertelstunde dauert, um da mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit erstmal hinzukommen.
Und die haben natürlich auch einen wahnsinnigen Datenstrom, den die da zurückschicken zur Erde. Megabyte- und Gigabyteweise schicken die da Daten in kürzester Zeit. Ich kann vielleicht mal kurz sagen, was wir für eine Datenrate zur Verfügung haben, um von Mars Express Daten zur Erde herunterzuschicken. Mit der besten Downloadrate haben wir 228 Kilobit. Das dauert alles ein bisschen länger. Wenn die Erde nah am Mars dran ist, im schlechtesten Fall geht das dann bis zu nur 28 Kilobit drunter.
Bei Venus Express ist es immer so, wenn die Venus hinter der Sonne verschwindet, dann gibt es Urlaub. Das ist dann wahrscheinlich bei euch ähnlich.
Ja, also Urlaub nicht wirklich. Es gibt hier noch viele andere Sachen am Standort zu tun. Man muss Reports schreiben, Dokumente herrichten, man muss am Kontrollsystem arbeiten und Simulationen durchführen und so weiter. Von daher gibt es nicht wirklich Urlaub.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Pause.
Es ist eine Art Betriebspause jedenfalls, weil der Satellit eine Pause macht. Das Raumfahrzeug selber macht eine kleine Pause von der Wissenschaft. Durch das Funksignal kann das von der Sonnenatmosphäre beeinflusst werden. Wenn der Mars, also quasi von der Erde aus gesehen, relativ nahe an der Sonne vorbeifliegt, ist dann in der nächsten Annäherung nur noch ein halbes Grad zwischen Mars- und Sonnenrand. Da das Signal nicht mehr gewährleisten kann, dass man Befehle sicher zum Raumfahrzeug transportieren kann und dass man vor allem die wissenschaftlichen Daten, die der Satellit aufnimmt, sicher zurück zur Erde bekommt, ohne irgendwelche verstümmelten Daten. Deswegen gibt es dann eine fünfwöchige Pause, wo der Satellit einfach nur in Warteposition, in sozusagen Parkposition, immer mit der Antenne zur Erde gerichtet, einfach nur abwartet, bis die Zeit vorbei ist. Man macht dabei allerdings trotzdem noch Wissenschaft, indem das Funksignal von der Erde aus immer beobachtet wird, wie die Qualität von dem Funksignal ist. Es werden also regelmäßig Testbefehle, so eine Art Ping-Befehle zum Raumfahrzeug geschickt. Und es wird dann an Bord aufgezeichnet, welche angekommen sind. Und von der Erde aus kann man dann auch noch die Antwort sehen, falls der Ping-Befehl angekommen ist und die Antwort zurückgeschickt wurde. Dann kann man auch darauf schließen, wie jetzt die Hin- und Rückverbindung funktioniert hat. Wie das Wetter gerade in verschiedenen Phasen. Genau.
Ja, haben wir es jetzt eigentlich, oder? Ich habe noch etwas ganz Dringendes vergessen, was du gerne noch erwähnt haben möchtest, was wir so ausgelassen haben.
Da fällt mir jetzt auf Anheben nichts ein.
Na gut, dann machen wir den Sack jetzt zu. Vielen Dank für die Ausführungen hier zu Mars Express. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Hier geht es dann bald weiter. Das ist sicherlich kein Geheimnis. Wir werden uns als Nächstes den Mars als solchen mal ein bisschen näher anschauen und vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen erfahren, was die neueste Mission noch so an zusätzlichem Wissen angereichert hat. Aber bis dahin, wir gehen jetzt erst mal wieder noch zwei Wochen. Sagt Tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.